vous arrivez 1re salif voilà auxonne à
une femme qui fait beaucoup pour le
village c'est le meilleur moi je suis là
chef cuistot de la guerre chaque jour
elle prépare un repas chaud pour les
soldats d'ukrainiens engagé ici dans les
combats sur les 500 habitants il reste
moins de 100 sacha connais cette famille
dont l'immeuble a été touché par des
tirs
venaient voir la cave
depuis le début de la guerre il vivait
au sous sol
sans eau sans électricité sans chauffage
terrorisés par les détonations et avec
bien peu d'espoir
regardez nous il n'y a aucune aide et
j'ai besoin du médicament
j'ai survécu à la deuxième guerre donc à
une coutume routine le pire qui terre
dans la cave glacial juste à côté nous
découvrons dans un lit sous de grosses
couvertures une vieille famille mobile
qui est venu maman n'est pas peur nous
sommes deux journalistes français
professeur d'histoire pendant 40 ans
dans le village aujourd'hui terrés au
fond d'une cave insalubre sans pouvoir
fuir la guerre est ce que vous demandez
à ce qu'on nous sorte de là aller où il
y à cette belle femme et une entre paray
de l'autre côté
roots and if frapper de toutes parts les
fermes les habitations l'école aussi
regardez là c'est la bibliothèque
scolaire pour les enfants au pied du mur
les restes du missile nous retrouvons
oksana la cuisinière devant chez elle ou
plutôt devant les restes de sa maison
c'est le joli cadeau que les russes nous
ont fait avec ce bombardement par terre
on voit les traces des chenilles des
chars russes qui sont passés dans le
village ils ont détruit une grande
partie de ville je sors actuellement
retranché à 2 3 kilomètres d'ici parce
que les russes sont partout parce que le
piège se referme cette famille a décidé
de fuir à pied